good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 525 object class
Euclid special containment procedures
outside of testing conditions the
individual components of SCP 525 must be
stored in separate sealed containers no
more than six components may be stored
in the same room or within 15 meters of
each other all currently existing
components are accounted for at storage
site 23 in lockers 2 only Class D
personnel are authorized to handle a CP
525 all supervising staff must wear
protective eyewear during testing
description scp-524
consists of multiple disjointed
arthropod legs 10 to 15 centimeters in
length DNA identification has been
inconclusive but the closest matched so
far is to the brown recluse spider lock
so selys reclusa the base of each leg
ends in several minut hooks capable of
perforating flesh as CP 525 is covered
in short fine hairs and is quite brittle
when alone are in proximity with fewer
than 6 others scp-524 is inert when
eight components of SCP 525 are brought
within range of each other approximately
0.6 meters the legs will immediately
crawl into a group and attach themselves
to a single entity referred to as 525
one at this stage the speed of its
locomotion greatly increases and it will
attempt to make contact with the closest
human or similar see addendum 525 a when
a suitable animal is found 525 one will
climb directly towards the animals I
having centered itself over a socket
four legs will secure the eyelid while
the others extract the eye
despite 525 ones rapid movements extreme
care is taken not to damage the eye
during the extraction severing the optic
nerves and central retinal vein once the
eye is free from the original owners
socket 525 one will implant the base of
each leg into the eye close inspection
shows that the hooks at the base extend
effectively rooting the leg in position
if allowed to remain 525 one will lay
what appeared to be eggs in the socket
of its host before climbing off see
document 525 a when in possession of an
eye
525 one is no longer hostile and its
movement is somewhat impeded curiously
525 one does not respond to visual
stimuli suggesting that it does not use
the eye for site dissection of a
chimpanzee eye taken by 525 one and
retained for a period of one week reveal
the formation of over time the ID
hydrates usually turning the same
reddish color as a CP 525 after two to
three weeks
525 one will abandon the eye and begin
to search for another
addendum 525 a 525 responds to most
large to moderate sized mammals reptiles
fish and birds have provoked little
response when exposed to Crocodylus
actus 525 one attempted extraction
managing to blind the animal but
otherwise failing thereafter all
instances of 525 have not responded to
crocodiles even those not present at the
initial experiment
document 5:25 a observation log of
subject D 1548 after exposure to 5:25
one report compiled by dr. Weiss dated
2000 week one medical staff on hand
attend to D 1548 14 avoids resembling
opaque tone eggs discover embedded in
the extraocular muscles three are
removed and sent to the research lab D
1548 placed under quarantine
week 2 D 1548 injury is healing as
normal eggs show marginal swelling D
1548 does not display unusual discomfort
eggs stored in the lab have Delic quest
week 3 D 1548 complains of increasing
phantom pressure in the socket D 1548
demands a mirror to inspect the injury
request denied
muscle tissue has healed over and
obscured the eggs week 4 D 1548
forcefully removes bandages and attempts
to dig into the socket is successfully
restrained 24 days after initial
exposure 11 fully formed components of a
CP 525 erupt from D 1548 socket and
begin to coalesce
okay you can all stop cringing now
because that about does it for today
thank you very much for listening and
you were all dismissed goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Muslim Mookie slump god Justin day
John Porter captain Gorge fluffy dread
my archive curator neck tie verbal
cootie tench cheese whip depths McGee
and oblong dish boy if you would like a
special Thank You the end of each of my
videos and some other cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
volgen thank you
[Music]
[Music]